sophie et rebecca sont des gens du
voyage ces caravanes sur leur maison
mais pour elle a pas question de prendre
la route elles ont toute leur vie ici
dans les yvelines
comme elle a 28 autres sédentaires
vivent sur l'air d'accueil desbruyères
attrape une aire inadaptée puisqu'elle
est prévu pour des gens de passage
séjour maximum cinq mois jusqu'à l'année
dernière
des dérogations leur était accordé mais
un nouveau règlement a changé la donne
seul exception avoir un enfant scolarisé
son n'a pas d'enfant qui va à l'école
faut qu'on soit expulsé mais s pulsé
poil et où on serait pas la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines gère les trois
aires d'accueil présente sur son
territoire dont celle ci elle assure
conseillers des places dans les environs
au bout des cinq mois mais ce que
demandent ces sédentaires c'est une
solution définitive obtenir une aire
familial c'est à dire une ère sans
limite de temps donc ça fait dix ans
qu'on fait les démarches soit reconnue
habitant de des yvelines est d'avoir un
terrain familiaux et les panneaux temps
de parler on a tout le département il
est pratiquement rien qui est prévu pour
eux il ya une sorte de terrain familial
qui a été instituée à plaisir il y en a
un qui s'assimile à un terrain familial
à aux clayes-sous-bois mais c'est tout
ailleurs rien n'a été prévu de cet ordre
donc nous militons justement pour que ça
soit prévue dans le cadre de programmes
d'habitat la casse qui reconnaît le
problème et renvoie la balle aux autres
villes du département de défauts
capacité d'accueil et d'autre l'ensemble
des communes avait réalisé d'accueil
vide juridique pour les gens du voyage
sédentaires ou manque de volonté
politique
il semble que sophie et les autres
résidents doivent encore attendre pour
être reconnus comme de vrais trappistes